la parole est à notre collègue alain
milon pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole pour 2 minutes 30
maximum
merci monsieur le président à ma
question s'adresse à la madame la
ministre de la santé madame la ministre
les médecins de france vous lance un cri
d'alarmé que le gouvernement ignore
après la mobilisation des médecins
généralistes à roanne les médecins
quimper ont lancé ces deux derniers
jours un vaste mouvement de protestation
contre la loi santé demain d'autres
villes prendront le relais mg france
réunis en assemblée générale le week-end
dernier et les autres syndicats de
médecins fmf csmf sml le bloc ont
réaffirmé leur opposition au tiers
payant obligatoire et généralisée nous
estimons comme les professionnels de
santé que la mise en place du tiers
payant obligatoire et généralisée n'est
pas une bonne mesure pour au moins trois
raisons la première au nom de la liberté
de choix des patients
demain ce sont les complémentaires santé
qui orienteront les patients vers telle
ou telle professionnels de santé comme
cela se fait déjà dans d'autres domaines
l'optique par exemple la deuxième au nom
de la liberté d'exercice
demain l'offre de soins va se réduire
les médecins ce des conventions seront
pour le moins ou ne s'installeront pas
pour le pire
la troisième au nom de la rupture du
contrat moral qui lie les médecins l
etat demain ce contrat seront sera rompu
unilatéralement par l'état et sans
concertation vous imposer une mesure
dont l'application est en plus d'une
rare complexité et tous les partenaires
possibles dénonce cette complicité et à
cause de cette complicité vous avez
d'ailleurs reporté sa réalisation en
les multiples réactions d'opposition des
médecins libéraux
face à cette mesure témoigne de leur
attachement à leurs conditions
d'exercice leur permettant de se
consacrer totalement à la médecine et
témoignent d'un refus des tâches
administratives elles ne sont pas le
produit comme certains peuvent
l'affirmer d'un corporatisme mais d'une
volonté de sauver
la médecine libérale mon adversaire de
la médecine salariée et pilier de la
santé publique dans notre pays
vous faites les membres du gouvernement
mûri au trône du système sans avoir rien
ni d'autres en place les médecins
généralistes principalement concernés
par cette mesure souhaite le retrait de
celle ci les entendrez vous enfin merci
mais parce que le président pour
répondre au président millions la parole
à madame la ministre de la santé madame
marie sur le touraine merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président milon le
texte de modernisation de notre système
de santé qui est actuellement en
discussion et qui arrivera à dans votre
hémicycle dans quelques semaines porte
tout un ensemble de mesures mesures de
prévention pour favoriser la prévente à
prise en charge de la santé précoce des
enfants et des jeunes adultes
propositions de mesures pour lever les
obstacles financiers que peuvent
rencontrer nos concitoyens mais aussi
les obstacles géographiques face aux
déserts médicaux mesures pour renforcer
le service public hospitalier et nous en
avons évoqué certaines tout à leur
mesure de démocratie sanitaire
je constate que autour de ce projet de
loi
reste la question du tiers payant comme
seul sujet de discussion avec des
professionnels qui pour le reste marc
leur engagement en faveur de la
prévention souhaite que l'organisation
de leur profession sur le territoire
soit mieux identifiée que les relations
avec l'hôpital soit plus solide et qui
marque leur attachement bien sûr à la
démocratie sanitaire
je peux vous dire monsieur le sénateur
que le tiers payant qui existe dans la
plupart des pays européens ne remet
nullement en cause l'exercice de la
médecine libérale nos concitoyens sont
attachés au choix de leurs médecins et
les médecins sont à juste titre attaché
à pouvoir exercer dans les conditions
qu'il souhaite pas plus que dans une
pharmacie lorsque vous
donnez votre carte vitale et que vous
bénéficiez du tiers payant
les pharmaciens se trouve inféodés aux
assureurs privés demain pas davantage
les médecins ne verront les conditions
de leur exercice remise en cause
il s'agit de mesures de simplification
plis cité et il s'agit de garantir à
tous nos concitoyens
l'accès à leur professionnel de santé
pour rassurer j'ai inscrit dans la loi
des mesures garantissant des délais de
paiement rapprocher garantissant une
organisation simplifiée à partir de
l'assurance maladie et garantissant une
mise en place au plus agressive à partir
du 1er juillet prochain
vous le voyez monsieur le sénateur le
débat est engagé et je suis certaine
qu'il se poursuivra dans les meilleures
conditions possibles avec l'ensemble des
professionnels